you have to be persistent you have to
you'll listen to all the no's uh which
we got many many of and uh and then just
keep pushing forward bring as much
passion as you can to something lead
with your heart build the right team
right management team and then just
build upon that and start to snowball
and that's really what we did at beyond
me
[Music]
well look i'm i'm honored to have you
here and i must start off by saying that
i'm a proud investor and i have to let
you know ethan that you
um you have a lot to do with why i went
plant-based to begin you the one of the
first examples i always go to when
talking about the uh the impacts can
have on someone's life and
and uh just you as a role model for kids
it's been amazing even aside from beyond
meat the carbon footprint and everything
now getting on to some of the questions
ethan so you started off in clean tech i
did how and why
yeah so when when i was younger and i uh
had a love for basketball but not the
same uh talent that you do so we had to
go do something else and uh
and i was sitting in my dad's office and
i was talking about kind of what i
should be doing
as i thought about my career you know he
asked me a question he asked me what is
the biggest problem in the world as you
see it and i thought about that for a
long time and to me it really came back
as being climate
and so
the correlate to that question was you
know then what do you do about it and at
the time
uh the thinking was really around uh
alternative energy so looking at ways to
migrate from fossil fuels to renewable
and cleaner sources of energy and there
was kind of a basket of different
technologies whether it was lithium-ion
batteries
solar cells wind fuel cells and i began
working on a number of those uh as a
kind of analyst and then
joined a company uh that that was
focused on hydrogen uh power
specifically uh proton exchange membrane
fuel cells and i loved it i loved
working in that space but i kept feeling
and i was missing something and that led
me to to the work that i'm doing now how
does clean tech get you to food like how
did that happen i mean first of all what
we're talking about in clean energy is
fuel to to to move things around to
warm buildings to uh provide the
electricity that we so uh enjoy
and things of that nature what we're
talking about in food is fuel for our
bodies and so there are some common
elements there but more importantly it
was through problem solving i began to
really think more about climate and
maybe a more sophisticated way than i
had when i was just a student
and started to think about the impact
that livestock has on climate and and it
to me just the sheer amount of land
energy water
and emissions that that are involved in
bringing a piece of protein uh to the
plate from an animal it was so
significant that i felt i had to go do
something about it
it's one thing to
know all of those working parts and all
the the different intricacies
um like me once i started eating healthy
right i started trying to figure out
what foods to eat
um
but you got
beyond meat
right like what what inspired you
right if you think about um what meat is
and this is really where i think things
get exciting uh meat is is a composition
that is very familiar to us and it's
essentially five things if you think
about it at a really high level it's
amino acids it's lipids it's trace
minerals it's vitamins and it's water
said more simply it's basically protein
fat and water
and what the animals doing is they're
consuming a large amount of vegetation
you know you look at bovine they're
they're eating
grass or being fed feed
and they're converting that plant
material through their digestive tract
and their skeletal muscular system
into uh center of the plate protein into
muscle right and we harvest that muscle
as we slaughter the animal pull it out
and then we prepare that as something we
put in the center of our plate well the
tremendous news here and this has to do
with the evolution of the earth
and our species within it is that
there's a commonality and a unity
between plants and animals in terms of
the core material parts so what you find
in plants you also find in in human and
animal bodies uh just presenting
differently but it's that combination of
proteins and fats and water that you can
pull those from plants
or you can get them from animals and our
idea was to just
not to make a soybean behave like a
steak but rather let's find the core
parts of meat in plants let's pull them
from the plants and let's assemble them
against the architecture or blueprint of
animal muscle or meat what was your
advantage right and how did you get
investors to believe in you right
because i'm sure when you came to some
people they were like
what is he talking about like
we're not trying to do this we like uh
we like to eat our meat we like this
stuff what is he talking about how did
you get investors to believe in what you
were building
i mean it's very similar and this is why
i love sports so much to
to to what i've seen you go through and
obviously i know so much about your
career as a fan and and uh the
persistence that you had to show um and
you know transitioning from football to
to basketball
uh so i think the biggest thing you know
when i was in business school people
would talk about oh you need a
competitive moat
and generally they would say that has to
be some advantage from a technology
perspective going into
a sector so that you can create a
competitive advantage that someone else
can't knock out
and unfortunately that's not really true
uh what you you do need is to work
harder than anybody to be smart and and
surround yourself with very smart people
but it's not like i went into this space
with an infallible technology
i went in with a very good technology
and one that was very good at creating
muscle structure
but it was what we've done after that
that really has helped uh propel the
company and so you have to be persistent
you have to um
you'll listen to all the no's which we
got many many of and uh and then just
keep pushing forward but
bring as much passion as you can to
something lead with your heart build the
right team right management team have
good technology and then just build upon
it and start to snowball and that's
really what we did at beyond me
what was it like for you though
when you were getting those no's and
then obviously
uh beyond meat is
very successful now
like do you remember a lot of those no's
and it's it's okay to have a chip on
your shoulder
uh well i love that it's funny i just
was texting one of my children about uh
they're they're going into practice i
said make sure you do play with a chip
on your shoulder because uh
you know you have to find some ways to
fuel yourself every day and and um so i
certainly do have that and in this room
here there are quotes on the wall from
people who have doubted us um you know
people in media and things like that
uh saying that this can't be done and i
use those a lot to motivate myself and
motivate my team
and um and so yeah i remember all of
them actually um where uh you know
you're sitting across from a table you
really need someone to to invest and
believe in you and you know they turn
you down and they turn you down again
and again and um
you know it's persistence and it's it's
it's a commitment to the product at the
end of the day like we have to keep
making the product better and better and
we have this program at beyond me
it's called beyond me rapid and
relentless innovation and uh talking
about sports again i actually stole that
word uh that use of that word from the
warriors back when when they were you
know just i went to a conference there
one day and they kept using that word i
said that's really what i want this team
to be doing within our labs is be
relentless on
being the best out there at taking
protein fats
minerals vitamins water from non-animal
sources and building them into the
structure of meat
and let's get better and better every
day and that's the only way to prove
people wrong and by the way with these
deals we just did with mcdonald's kfc
pizza and taco bell
our promise them is that we will
out-compete the other people in the
market like we will just bring you the
best product and and that's how
we have to build our reputation and how
we have to build our company is is not
through you can try to get contracts
where you force people to take your
products or what have you better way to
live and a better way to do things is
just always produce the best product and
so um you know as i was getting those
no's i just went home and made the
product better just went you know worked
with my team to make the product better
and better and better and once you do
that
at that point you start to see customers
come to you you start seeing investors
come to you
being in athletics my entire life
playing football playing basketball and
especially when i made it to the nba
everyone used to always ask the question
when did you know that you were gonna
make it right like
you have some prodigies that know
they're gonna make it when they're in
middle school now and i always say for
me
i didn't know till probably my sophomore
year in college that's when i really was
like
i'm ready i'm ready i can go to the nba
i know i know i'll be ready when did you
know that you were onto something
so i have this thing where um
i never thought the business would fail
i didn't know how it come out though you
know i just didn't i didn't
you know we talked about how do you get
through the nose and stuff and one of
the ways is to
cut your safety net completely all right
and i didn't necessarily do that
consciously but i did it anyway and what
i mean by that is you had a very good
job and and uh had uh you know
some savings and home and all this stuff
but you know you you say i'm never going
to touch those savings
but you do and you burn through them and
then you know i'm not going to sell that
house but you do you know and so then
it's not so much bravery that keeps you
going it's just you got to i'm sharing
that because you know even today
uh you have to have a healthy amount of
um i don't know if it's fear or a belief
that you need to keep pushing hard to be
successful that you can't rest right and
and so
one of the things i love about
particularly college coaches uh and even
mba coaches is how many times you see an
mba coach like you know smiling and
dancing up and down when when they win
they look relieved like if you look at
like coach k when he wins he's like he
just likes relief right you know and
that's sort of the sense of what you
when you have a business like this and
or a career i said like yours you know
oftentimes it's just a relief to have
one and i feel that way uh as we as
we're growing our business
and so i would say the moment that i
felt like my god this is actually
turning and and this is something that
could have a global impact
which we started getting these large
quick serve restaurants uh and so you
know one of the first was a w
uh and then here in southern california
carl's and
and del taco but then in canada
mcdonald's
and i went there myself i was in toronto
and they did the test in a rural area
and i got in the car late at night i
drove out there and uh
sat down in the restaurant i had it i
got that feeling of like you know really
can't believe it's happening and that
was a blessing for me and and uh
a wonderful feeling you created a
product that didn't exist before right
so you're an inventor
like what what was
you laughing about it but that's the
truth like
sometimes people will come out with
something that already exists and just
try to make a better version of it you
really invented something so
what was your biggest obstacle
yeah there were a lot um
the first obstacle was myself you know
was just um
convincing myself that
well answering a calling basically that
if i you know if i didn't do this would
i be happy in life you know and
it takes a lot to get yourself out of
you know a routine where you're paying
for your mortgage you're saving money
and all that stuff to do something
that's so that that is is outside of
your field and so for me it just as a
discomfort started to build as i you
know said i really have to go do this
and satisfy this issue so that was the
first obstacle was was getting over my
own
sense of trepidation about it um and
then second uh
you know it was just this constant need
to
uh overcome
the uh there's a cultural barrier to
this that still exists today um that you
know i think one of the reasons that i
find your work for with us and your work
overall
on this subject so incredibly compelling
is we have to displace
attack head-on
uh it really something that's a
scientific and that that is that animal
protein is better for you in terms of
athleticism and everything else than
plant protein what's true is that a
complete set of amino acids is really
good for you right as an athlete and
healthy clean fats are really good for
you we can take all those from plants
and build them uh into the structure of
meat so that you can satisfy and and and
grow your body and and perform at your
highest level
um but yet there's a cultural stereotype
it's the exact opposite you know and so
there's this idea that to be a robust
athlete and to be a
masculine presence that you need to have
animal protein and it's just a
scientific so we have to we had to get
through that and we're still trying to
get through that uh and because the
irony is that if you do want to perform
at the highest level
cleaning your body of some of the things
that are in animal protein is the way to
go
and so we're just learning so much about
the role that food can play whether it's
in you know the the inflammation you
feel on your knees or
potential precursor or contributor
rather to to alzheimer's disease
to heart disease inflammation is the
root of so many of the things that are
causing these diseases that are so
horrific and we can influence those
through the food we eat through how it
conditions our microbiome and the
bacteria in our gut
and we can play a role with that at the
ami
trust me ethan everything you're saying
right now is i told you it's been
life-changing for me and i think
what you're saying is so important
because it's the education
component of it and i think that's what
so many people lack in general but
especially the african uh
african-american community um
my aunts and uncles my dad i think for
me
uh this change in lifestyle as far as
diet and eating
it really hit me hard and it started off
performance based but then it became
life based right and if no one else ever
listens to me when i get on one of my
rants are talking about how to eat
healthy and what it does for your gut uh
my dad turned 60 this past year and um
you know i was driving on the highway
and my dad called me and he called me on
facetime and he was in tears
and he was just telling me that he went
to the doctor and the doctor had told
him that his health was so much better
was so much better so um i thank you for
educating me to begin with so that i can
try to educate those around me so um
off of that moment right there so one of
the things too um
that obviously people know is that
beyond meat is still more expensive than
regular meat right and i know that you
said that that will flip like when and
what will it take to make that happen
so we set a goal two years ago to within
five years uh be able to underprice
animal protein in at least one category
and that's so important uh because right
now we're asking the question of the
consumer let's say in a quick serve
restaurant
do they want to transition uh or
substitute a plant-based meat uh into
their diet
uh but also do they want to pay more
more for it and we gotta get away from
that second question the second question
not helpful and what's terrific about
what we're doing
if you believe in this model of
efficiency we talk about the animal
being the biggest bottleneck in
agriculture so we have increased the
efficiency of our fields
over the last hundred years an
incredible amount right so you know corn
soy and wheat we're growing huge uh
usually more
uh quantities per acre than ever before
in human history
but what are we doing with that we're
running it through the same system to
convert it into into into meat which is
the animal and the animal is largely
standing still in the sense that the
animal is not evolving
at a pace that we can see anyway
into a more efficient bioreactor so if
we remove the animal and we put in this
technology which takes two to three
minutes to create that muscle-like
structure
uh we should become
less expensive uh we have tremendous
efficiency advantages over
over uh animal protein and we had
michigan university of michigan do this
great study where we use 99 less water
93 less land so why are we more
expensive it doesn't make sense the
inputs are you know plants they're
things like peas and you know fava bean
and uh things that are ready available
in agriculture the answer has entirely
to do which was the scale of our
business so if you think about tyson or
jbs you know you look at how much food
they are producing i heard at one point
that tyson was touching two out of every
five plates in the united states so they
have a scale advantage over us and we
have to continue to scale our business
we have to continue to mature our supply
chain enter more competition into our
supply chain so we can get lower cost
inputs
but we're doing all that now and we're
on that cost curve so if you think about
the computer industry or the
semiconductor industry or
any of these technologies come along we
are going to make this cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper to the point where
we'll underprice animal protein why is
that so important for obvious reasons
but but we'll get closer and closer uh
to
the animal protein that we're trying to
uh provide a an alternative to in terms
of the century experience the taste the
aroma the appearance all of that stuff
will keep getting better every year
second we'll get the nutrition to the
point where everyone understands that
point right right now there's a lot of
noise about process and all this stuff
we're gonna do a lot of education about
why this product is healthier for you
right so
taste health and then you drop the price
below animal protein it becomes a rare
consumer that says this tastes just like
animal protein it's better for me and
it's cheaper i'm still not going to eat
it so we've got to get those three
things done and we've got to get them
done in the next uh next few years right
because my next question was going gonna
be for for me
um
it was somewhat easy to convert me right
because
the inflammation me being an athlete
right but how do you convert the
die-hard meat-eaters
independent of ideological boundaries or
or you know socio-economic
uh all the divisions that we have in our
society
uh you're still seeing people uh take uh
this step and become largely flexitarian
and uh it's driven primarily by health
you know it doesn't matter whether
you're in a field in idaho or one of the
densest urban neighborhoods in the
united states on the coast or in chicago
or what have you
if your doctor tells you that you're
going to die if you don't change
something right you're going to listen
and not everybody listens but enough
people are listening where they're
breaking through and they're they're
setting aside stereotypes and things
that are that are not serving them and
so um for us health is the number one
message and that differentiates us by
the way from some of the companies that
are out there you know when we talk
about our ingredients we say you know
first of all it wouldn't be responsible
to load our product up with high levels
of saturated fat so we're always going
to offer the consumer uh if you look at
our burger um significantly less less
saturated fat than what's in uh in beef
right so we have i think in in the
beyond burger 3.0 we have 35 less
saturated fat in in in one of the
versions and then second which is meant
to be a lean burger we have 55 less
saturated fat we have you know no gmos
so there's no um uh you know novel
ingredients there it's just we're using
the plant kingdom in in ways that
present it to the human central
experience as an animal protein uh and
then no heterosexual amines all of the
things that are of concern within the
medical community about animal protein
we have kept out of our products right
uh or minimized and so
we have to keep conveying to people uh
the health benefits of eating and that's
the quickest way to their plate
last but not least um
you know
everyone defines this differently what
is success to you what does success look
like to you when it comes to you and
your company
you know it really um
we're trying to do something and when i
say we you you know we're all in this
doing this together to
to help
you know save lives and help people live
a healthier life and to to help repair
our planet
success for me is seeing as many people
as possible
in the locations that they love to eat
and that's why i'm so focused on places
like mcdonald's and kfc and others
um
enjoy themselves enjoy the meal have
great tasting products but doing a way
better for their bodies and doing what's
better for the earth
and so that's really how we do measure
success here um it's a mission you know
it's uh it's something that's very
personal
and uh you know we hope to look back and
be that group of people that separated
me from animals and brought the benefits
that that brings
to not only humans but the rest of life
on earth
well listen ethan thank you so much uh i
appreciate you giving us all this
insight all this wisdom thanks man
you